from Middle East i.net Israel Palestine
War jordanians tried to storm Israeli
Embassy after Gaza Hospital attack we
have this tweet lowkey online I'm not
sure who lowkey is uh host a podcast on
mint press news says the Israeli Embassy
in Jordan is on fire and this was posted
3:19 p.m. uh today so several hours ago
but uh this has been ongoing I I don't
know if we have uh yeah we have this
video here from the post millennial that
I'll play for you guys just a short
video showing what appears to be
thousands Maybe tens of thousands of
people outside the US and Israeli
embassies and of course again the
reporting is that they've tried to storm
the embassy so uh look
man I don't see how we get we get we get
out of this without at least widespread
war in the region whether it involves us
or not I feel clearly is going to it's
we we are not just going to be dragged
in we're going to like jump in which is
what we seem to be doing Biden's jumping
in right now Will lindsy Graham be on
ground lindsy Graham lindsy Graham won't
do anything L GR I've been calling him
the Anthony fouchy of War
interesting he's got his whole deal that
guy is crazy I can understand if our
interests are attacked and someone says
we should defend our interests fine I
will argue we should not have interests
in certain areas and so my argument
would be thus we should not be involved
for those reasons if the president is
attacked it's a tough position but for
Lindsey Graham to come out and say with
or without evidence the US should bomb
Iran is psychotic that is psychotic bomb
be a totally wacky thing to do it's
insane I I I he wants it I mean he's
going to make people will make money off
of war and he's probably one of those
people he's like buying a bunch of stock
in rathon and
Lock would point out just to be clear is
and some people might not remember or
know this but there are tens of
thousands of Palestinians living in
Jordan uh in refugee camps now for the
last several decades so this there there
is a huge Palestinian presence in Jordan
so perhaps and Jordan isn't accepting
them into their society at large correct
why are they not doing that well they
don't Lebanon either they're also in
refugee camps that why are they keeping
these people in refugee camps it's it's
an interesting thing why are they doing
that well one of the main reasons might
be because of the I don't know if I
think is Hamas Sunni are they Sunni is
that correct or Shia no
they're bah is Shia that's right
Hezbollah is is Shia so that's what
maybe the issue with well I was going to
say that may have been the issue of them
being Shia going to Sunni country but if
they're both Sunni and they both have
the same alignment I don't know if
Jordan is Shia or Sunni and know that
area is where in the center and Sunni
Sunni yeah Jordan Sunni and Hezbollah is
Shia right that's correct and that's
what's interesting about Hezbollah and
Hamas being friendly is because they're
sun and Shia and they disagree with
fundamental facts about their religion
but that's what I was wondering if why
that was why the people from from the W
from Gaza were not being accepted but
that is uh I don't really know anything
else beyond that you know but obviously
they have a common enemy so think about
Bashar al- Assad right so he is an
alawite and alawites are an offshoot of
sh uh Shia Islam they're not in direct
alignment the alites with the Iranians
but the Iranians came in and supported
them in what in that war right and so
it's obviously uh
relationship of convenience and I mean
they have a common common enemy right we
don't have a lot of Christian sects
going around fighting each other ever
since uh the British worked their thing
out with the Catholic Irish yeah we
don't see a lot of like inter war
between Christian groups as an Irish
Catholic I don't know if that's
completely worked out yet but uh you
know it's working out better than it is
yes yes no no no no it is working out a
lot better than I have been giving that
some thought though like when you think
about it so here in the US we have a lot
of we've seen all of these groups start
protesting in favor of Hamas essentially
um on college campuses and in Dearborn
Michigan and a lot of City centers we've
seen that in Times Square you know you
see people out with cfas and whatever
and there's they're all being supported
in a lot of cases these are people who
are being supported by not for-profits
in the US you know so you have not
for-profits like care what is it the cir
yeah they're supporting this stuff they
probably have an IRS tax designation
making them a charity so that they can
be funded and all I could think of when
I start thinking about this and where's
this money coming from in the US to F
fuel the protesters in the US who are
backing Hamas is the uh Catholic
churches in the 1980s um in the US that
would collect donations to repair the
roofs of the churches in Ireland AKA
going to Ira Rashida T has tweeted out
apparently um that Israel did bomb a a
Baptist Hospital killing 500
Palestinians doctors children and
patients and then blames the president
Brian kenen is criticizing her because
it's not confirmed but this is the point
I was making I mean it's already out
well she's a congresswoman so she must
be right she's a congresswoman yeah yeah
she has America's best interest in her
I'm sure that's why she's got that
Palestinian flag outside her
office she's it's true so now what's
going to happen is the people who who
like her are going to say it's true she
said so that's it end of story yep it
doesn't matter what the truth is no it's
relative terrifying since you brought it
up the interesting thing though about
Northern Ireland and I'm not going to go
down a rabbit hole on this is that they
did end up coming to through the Good
Friday agreements some type of formal
structure look if the people of Northern
Ireland now through referendum vote to
be to rejoin uh the Republic of Ireland
that's what's going to happen in the
British government is going to recognize
that and they were able to come up with
some type of uh political solution here
I have no I you're not going to get a
political solution here no no it's not
going to happen it's just not going to
happen this is this is scary stuff man I
mean if you're just on Twitter right now
if you're on X there's a lot of videos
flying around that are unconfirmed that
are going to lead us into very serious
conflict there's one post not confirmed
that a crowd in Turkey is trying to
break into a military base a US military
base and that the US they're saying the
US must respond and Protect US Territory
I don't know if this is true I see magin
noaz tweeted it from uh from Jason J
smart no idea where the video came from
but people are going to start seeing
these videos and it doesn't matter if
they get debunked later on you know
people people saw that's it they're not
going to look for the fact check and the
scary thing is Tim is that you have like
a
congresswoman who is feeding this social
media frenzy who could if she wanted to
go get some classified briefing and
actually understand probably much better
than all of us yeah what's actually
happening but she has no interest in
that she wants to fuel the propaganda
out there blind support blind support is
better than support that has any
knowledge of anything that's going on
because you can tell them exactly what
you wanted to know you can you are the
person who controls the information at
that point that's that's terrifying man
yeah and look I mean she's got her Flags
out there in front of her office I'm
sure Hamas is just waiting for the day
to raise the Palestinian and lgbtq flag
uh
Plus thank you yeah yeah um ites you say
Plus's it does seem weird that she is a
sitting congresswoman who is going after
one of our allies on Twitter that seems
bizarre right yeah well she's an
anti-semite she does hate Jew she's like
a classic Jew hater that is true we have
a number of them in Congress it turns
out I look look guys you know the left
would come out and say everyone on the
right is fascist and that is clearly
false because you can't call Dave Smith
a trump supporter because he's critical
of trump but they tried doing it when he
was on he was on Fox Business I think
with Kennedy and they were like you
Trump supporter like I don't support
Trump what are you talking about but
when you were looking specifically at
Rashida tay with the Palestinian flag
blaming Israel for something that's
unconfirmed and the involvement of of
the DSA their support for the like overt
support for
Hamas yet we're not being cute when she
say she's anti-semitic that's just like
a confirmed statement to no it's just
that's just a fact
yes she is Rashida Talib so is ilhan
Omar yes now hold on AOC called for
surgical I'm sorry precision and
intelligence to deal with Hamas I was
actually kind of impressed I was like I
don't know if I agree precision and
intelligence not not two words I usually
associate with her AOC AOC is getting a
lot of flak for for uh for this because
she's calling for a ceasefire and I I I
don't know why she it's like the the
hate against her right now is just pure
tribalism yeah okay ceasefire she she
she's asked about on CNN she's like this
goes both ways Hamas is firing Rockets
into Israel we want it to stop she's not
saying Israel should just not respond to
the attack saying Hamas needs to stop
too right I can certainly understand
Israel saying we're going after the
military leaders and then aoc's basic
assessment which again she's getting
ragged on for was Collective punishment
is not a good is not good and may
destabilize the region Hamas must be
dealt with but we need military
intelligence and precision
and I was like AOC went on television
and said that we should provide
intelligence to surgically strike and
and assassinate or execute Hamas leaders
and and she's getting raged by
Republicans I'm like what what what is
she supposed to say indiscriminately
bomb hospitals I don't understand like
she's giving what would probably be a
typical Republican answer military
surgical strikes on Hamas leadership and
she's getting raged I'm like I don't
know what to say to that yeah tribalism
right sometimes she is right just
recently I had I agreed with her on uh
her UFO assessment when she was like uh
basically I think this is her saying it
we give billions of dollars to a lot of
Corporations with no oversight and
they're creating things that we might
not know about yeah and that's I'm like
I agree a that's actually not too dumb I
agree I tried I tried writing a story
about her and then I think they Googled
me I reached out to her team they like
never mind I was this close wondering
when the left is going to come after AOC
for saying Hamas must be dealt with yeah
out of the squad and she and she like
she didn't literally say we need
surgical strikes to remove leadership
she says Hamas must be dealt with and
then she's asked how and she goes
perhaps with Military Intelligence or
precision and it's just like she's
basically saying too many civilians are
dying in Israeli air strikes they need
to be more precise and who they're
targeting and it's like Fair that's
that's more that's more Pro military
than I get coming from AOC right yeah I
mean the Striking thing though you know
through all of this yes we need to go
after Hamas they must be destroyed we
must go after after the leadership we
can't have these types of attacks on
Israel where's the Secretary of State
dealing with Egypt to get these
civilians out of there I mean has
anybody seen the Secretary of State I
mean I guess he's supposed to go over
there right he's been over there he had
a meeting he had like an eight hour
meeting yesterday talking to people if
you go to the state department he is in
is he's traveling to Israel Jordan
cutter Bahrain Saudi Arabia UA and Egypt
he's trying to get all this stuff sorted
out I don't agree with blinkin on pretty
much anything but that's where he is
he's over there and he's the one who
announced that Biden was going to be
coming by but you know what I think is
that they have dragged their feet on
those types of relationships because
Trump is the guy that did the Abram
Accords right and so that was such a
great idea the Abraham Accords yeah and
and they have I think not wanted to
solidify and strengthen that agreement
that Trump were he not Donald Trump
would have received the Nobel Peace
Prize for doing something like that he
was not there were a couple people
nominated him I I recall yeah I mean to
be able to get uh Arab Nations like that
to be able to recognize and normalize
relations with the state of Israel is a
huge accomplishment and I think that
they've dragged their feet on that
accomplishment because they don't want
it to be cemented in place and now we're
paying the price for that because I
would imagine they've not uh kept up the
pressure in terms of normalization of
those um uh interactions between those
two countries the most notable thing
I've seen blinkin do recently is like
play guitar at uh the White House I
don't know if anybody saw that I missed
that one entirely yeah he's he's
actually not bad at Guitar really yeah
is he as good at guitar as lizo was on
James Madison's I I I I think he's
better really he did he twerk no but I
think he was playing like jazz are Blues
he's actually pretty good all right
interesting yeah all right I think the
the the Abraham Accords were so
underreported I remember talking to
people about them who were like on the
left and they're like we never heard
anything about that and they you know
they're only watching CNN and NBC but
I'm like they were obviously
purposefully underreported they couldn't
give Trump anything no no and remember
they said oh we're going to have War uh
when Trump moves the embassy to
Jerusalem it's going to be you know holy
war turned out okay turned out okay
actually worked out aren't we glad we
don't have the embassy in Tel Aviv right
now thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net